so dave chappelle
i graduated from duke ellington high
school
and duke ellington high school is what
he credits with spurring his interest in
the arts and creativity
and so this high school
was planning on naming its new theater
after chappelle
but then dave chappelle did that
vaguely not totally woke comedy special
recently on netflix and now there are
protests not to name the school after
him
so
here's dave chappelle's response he said
quote
naming the theater after him is quote
the most significant honor of my life
and he proposed a
contest
he said the people who don't want it
named after me can raise some money for
the school i'm going to raise some money
for this school and the people who do
want it named after me or who are
neutral and whichever one raises more
money their way goes
it says whichever opinion donates the
highest collective dollar amount wins if
by april those against the chappelle
theater exceed the donations of those
who are neutral or in favor of the
theater being named chappelle i will
gladly step aside if not i will happily
attend the naming ceremony and if you
don't care enough to donate please shut
the f up forever dave
and this is a great way to do it because
no matter who which
side wins the school is going to get
more donation so i think it's a classy
way to do it
but this is also the way to engage in
the culture
i think the squish
attitude which has been the attitude of
many people on the right
for a couple of decades has been
you know let them have it they want it
let them have it they don't you don't
want the school named after me okay fine
i don't that's i don't need your school
named after me or your theater named
after me okay hey you want you want you
want to do your own thing you do your
own thing i'll do my own thing it's fine
who cares you do you
that's not what dave's doing dave is
saying no you are going to
sit in my theater the dave chappelle
theater i'm not going to let you have it
i'm not going to let you do whatever you
want i'm not going to let you have your
own way i am going to force my will upon
you because my will happens to be more
in accord with logic and reason and
things that are good and you're awful
cancel culture woke left just use
whatever term you want
your desires are bad and so i'm gonna
stop your desires i'm gonna push my
desires and deal with it deal with it
buddy that's the right attitude that's
the attitude that the right needs to
have
cert there is no way to have a society
in which
we don't hold certain beliefs about what
is good or what is freedom or what is
equality or what is what we should be
pursuing right some view is always going
to predominate
and so it's either going to be ours or
it's going to be the other guys do you
want it to be the other guys do you want
it to be the crazy radical left that
wants to destroy everything you cherish
or not the cathedral of notre dame it's
either going to be a christian cathedral
or it's going to be a secular liberal
cathedral or it's going to be a mosque
or it's but it's going to be something
it can't be nothing there's no
neutrality all right you've got to pick
and i love that dave is saying no you
don't get my theater you don't get my
theater buster
and i don't think that we should allow
the left
to have our communities or our states
or our families or our nation i'm glad
you like that clip now hold on before
you go
ring the bell please please that'd be
great ring the bell subscribe you
theoretically will get notifications to
these videos and if our pals at big tech
don't want you to you definitely should
head on over to apple podcast spotify
stitch or google play wherever you get
your audio podcast subscribe for free to
the michael knowles show leave a five
star review we'll see you next time
[Music]